we're here today with one of my favorite
actors a very ride-or-die sweaty a man
that knows his comics and a man who has
directed and written a movie which he
also stars in Seth Green I don't know
how you doing thanks I'm so excited to
talk about this movie I've been thinking
about it non-stop it is one of those
movies that it fills a void I didn't
know I had it's a type of movie that I
missed and the entire time from start to
finish I was just so warm and happy oh
good fantastic
thanks man so when you were shaping this
movie to me it reminded me of that
timeless feel the movie where you don't
know a decade it takes place in and you
don't know when it's supposed to be it
just feels like a complete film and
that's so hard to find now I don't have
to read I don't have to study after it's
just a movie when you were shaping the
script was that intentional I guess but
not I wasn't thinking about it as
consciously as that I I had taken a trip
with one of my best friends Dan and we
were in Thailand and everything that
happened to us from us being mistaken as
a honeymooning couple to you know
hopping into canoes and visiting James
Bond Island it was all stuff that
actually happened to us and the whole
experience the people that we met the
the types of interactions we were having
it all felt like a movie and so I
started taking pictures and imagining
that this would be a film you know kind
of like an early 90s Soderbergh and my
best bet just like a slice of life
people experiencing something and
working things out and what was the
point when you were like I'm gonna
direct a feature film this is definitely
a thing that is in my purview and I will
set out and accomplish it because this
doesn't look like someone's first
feature film by the way it looks amazing
well thanks um I don't remember there
being a moment where I looked at it with
that kind of resonance and you thought I
am going to direct a feature it was more
well I really love to tell this story I
think this would be a compelling piece
of cinema and there's no way for me to
convey these ideas to anyone for them to
be able to represent it and also we
didn't have any money I knew to really
pull this off we were gonna have to do
it as inexpensively as possible and I
wanted to put everything on screen so
more as a matter of course it made sense
for me to be able to
if I do three jobs we don't have to pay
to other people kind of and also there'd
be a shorthand I knew that because I had
written it that I could safely say on
set what was or was not the movie and so
as things happened as actors had ideas
as location obstacles presented
themselves or even just over the course
of making it you have to answer
questions I knew I'd been in a unique
position to say that is there is not the
movie now you cast a lot of people you
know well and you have that shorthand
and that as well like not only just
between you and you but between you and
friends and people unset when you were
shaping the story were there people that
you added in late in the game you're
like oh that's perfect was there like a
aha moment with a cast member not with
the casting more with the characters I
rewrote the script at least six times
completely where it's the same set
pieces and the same basic through-line
I'm still talking about the same topics
love and friendship and forgiveness and
the life you choose versus the life you
think that you're supposed to live but
but things evolved over time most of the
characters I wrote specifically for
actors that I knew would be able to
handle it would be able to give me
something that was really valuable and
also that we're professional enough to
just give it to me great in a taker -
mm-hmm yeah but you don't you stack the
deck in your favorite when you make
something like this you try and surround
yourself with the safest gang of awesome
people so that it works yeah you
mentioned Soderbergh were there any
other influences like through you you've
been decades of filmmaking whether there
are people that inspired you and like
Ana directing style yeah I love movies
but but this type of movie it was you
know I really loved how sideways got put
together which is very different than
most of Alexander Payne's movies I love
Garden State which which oddly enough is
different than Zach's other movies it's
like the right person for the right
story at the right time so you are
you're working in a long tradition here
in terms of the transformative
travelogue was there anything that you
definitely wanted to accomplish or stay
away from or like how did that like body
of work the idea as you were planning
this one out I really just tried to stay
true to the story itself I just I I had
been so inspired by
and all the different characters that we
met in the way that everyone had found
their way there through different
circumstances I like the idea of
different people solving their own
life's questions in completely different
ways but being personally happy
nonetheless sorry guys I got a catch I
really enjoyed and I don't want to give
anything away so I'm just gonna do vague
book here but I love that with your
career you've always been able to choose
genre content because I know how much
you love jean rrah content of your own
like comics and the sci-fi in that world
and there are so many impossibly subtle
things that I'm not gonna give away but
the entire time I was going like a nerd
made this yeah and was that something on
set like how early was that a conscious
choice I don't know I mean you just have
fun with what's you once you're once you
feel like you're doing diligent service
to the story anything the ad that
doesn't compete with the audience's
ability to interpret I think is fair
game and so to that end I just thought
it would be really funny to put a lot of
stuff in that only if you knew that
that's a thing would that be something
you'd notice but nothing that would be
actually distracting you know or so
intentional that the audience is like
what is that right right and that's what
it felt like it was definitely that the
deeper cuts good so you've been making
stuff for a long time now you've been
involved in Hollywood for a long time
now what was new and different about
this experience about these challenges
well I guess it was just the doing it
like the actual doing it I've gotten to
direct a bunch of stuff I've gotten to
work with a lot of actors I've been on
you know over I've gotten to work on
over 40 movies so I've got no watch
actors and directors and producers I've
gotten to see all the things they do
right and wrong and I pay really close
attention so I didn't try to set myself
up for something that was so showy
because my goal is not to like look at
me I'm a director I really just wanted
to tell the story well and make this
movie as effectively as possible it's
one of those movies for me that I was
enjoying it so much I was introspective
about my own life I really liked that
the message made you reflect on yourself
and I
really the the whole perspective on
partnership really struck me and it was
it was such great storytelling visually
and narrative ly were there other cuts
were you had like different elements
like I you said you rewrote it six times
but did it really landed visually and
like here oh thank you I am you know I
had always been told that you make three
movies there's a movie you write because
you have to write in a particular way
with a certain amount of dialogue and a
certain type of stage direction for the
reader to be able to understand and
connect with what you're doing and then
there's the movie you shoot which allows
for discovery and complications that you
know breed invention and you have to
sort of adjust to what's actually
happening you're in a scene and realize
oh this this can't go this way or you
know we'll be better as if you said this
and then there's the movie that you edit
because when you get it all home and you
got to make a movie different and I
wound up being able to trim certain bits
of dialogue in fact dialogue I thought
was the sum total of the point of the
movie I was able to extract in favor of
playing a moment just as a look between
two characters or something where a
music you took took control you're like
we did this so well that you don't have
to actually say what it was any longer
well I mean that's what you hope for but
I had heard that from a lot of people
and that well III had originally cut a
version of it that was an hour 47
knowing that I was gonna cut a half an
hour out of the movie and then I let
friends of mine who were directors or
producers or storytellers and I let them
look at it and I got some incredible
advice back like everyone took the time
to watch it and tell me something that
was very very helpful that's fantastic
and I can only happen in this like the
collaborative nature of film is so
important and this reads is very
collaborative you also got to be okay
with taking the hit when people are
saying it's just not working it's
absolutely not working like this doesn't
work I don't like this character you
completely missed this moment what are
you trying to accomplish here cuz it's
not playing and then you as the director
are like well instead of being like what
don't you get it don't you get it I'm
doing this you just have to go okay well
I clearly haven't done my job well
enough if the audience isn't receiving
it the way I've intended for any
creatives out watching right now what
was a big
learning moment for you is anything that
you will do differently for your second
film just as an actor it is very
difficult to I think I took a lot for
granted as a performer I did a lot of
work in advance and then because I wrote
the character I had an expectation of
what I would need on set and because I
was on set calling action calling cut in
a scene and I'd give everyone else their
information and then we were just like
roll and shoot I definitely would do
that just a little bit differently if I
ever do it again but I also didn't take
the time to go back and look at takes on
the monitor because that fundamentally
wastes its time and when you're making a
movie for this little money under these
kind of circumstances you just needed to
keep moving yeah that would have meant a
lot of trust in your team I assume yeah
well like I said I packed all of the
areas with a valuable team and a lot of
support so I had you know producers
behind the camera be like I think we
need another one or any of the other
actors were all very communicative about
how it played now I loved he's on the
poster so it's safe to say matt kokkonen
this is i all the choices he makes
beautifully fantastic it was it was so
good to see that character when did you
decide to bring your friends to Thailand
like I know I know the inception of the
story but when was the decision to be
like hey let's actually make this a
journey was it like a year out like how
long was the once once it was landed
once you're ready to go I don't know I
think I had been telling everybody that
was cast in the movie that I've been
writing parts for them for several years
and everybody knew abstractly about this
Thailand movie that I was gonna try and
put together but I didn't let anybody
read the script until I was sure it was
at least a version of the movie we could
make and when we started going out and
getting financing for it that that's
when it became a reality you don't want
anybody to have a bad experience and I
would have been horrified if any of my
friends passed after I go through all
this day like with Mack it's a it's a
great example this character Ian was a
character that my friend Dan and I met
when we were in Thailand there was a guy
who was the captain of our snorkel boat
tour and he's not as outrageous or as
wild
as Mac is in the movie but the character
needs to be more exaggerated for the
benefit of the film and I had always
told him that I was writing this part
because he was the best person to play
it you know Mac doesn't care about
maintaining his own celebrity or like
trying to nurture his career he's really
just quite happy doing whatever he wants
to do and so I was very happy that he
gave me the goods on this movie because
I think it's an invaluable part of the
film it is and it's a very funny one and
it's one of the the like comic
highlights as you weave between tones
now did the choice of balancing comedy
and drama and and all of that for this
just come out of this being a story you
wanted to tell cuz obviously you've
worked in every kind of story there is
well thanks well I had written a version
of this that was far harder of an
r-rated comedy as one of my first drafts
and it felt just disingenuous to what I
was trying to make ultimately and even
though I do like that balance I feel
like the comedy in this movie is less
farcical you know set piece based comedy
and more just sort of the novelty that
comes with life one of the things I
liked most was how you slice a life and
that's so hard to accomplish especially
as we get desensitized to life like in
the world or in these spectacle films
and it feels like you're just in that
page so now that we're on clatter heroes
I gotta switch gears to comic books The
Odyssey we're living in the world of
reality in your movie but you know the
world of comics so well you're in
someone stronger content is there
anything you're reading right now that
you're totally vibing with well yeah you
and I had that awesome the comic book
shopping day and as a result I got
turned on to a bunch of stuff I really
have not been out of it but haven't put
focus on staying current or reading new
stuff and I you know it's to my own
detriment
it just means every time you tune back
in it's like it was a boatload of no
amazing stuff which is pretty great I've
been enjoying that yeah I've been
reading that sidarsky Peter Parker yeah
I've been really enjoying you gave me a
couple of those collected quick so I
just been working my way through that
his comedy is is insane and he gets the
voice of spider-man I think super well
yeah spider-man's my favorite so we were
talking spider-verse right before yeah
and it's been out long enough I can
safely say spoilers are fair game - you
haven't seen spider-verse you're
watching the wrong show yeah for your
first experience into it seeing like
syncovich is kingpin are like ultimate
green goblin seeing all of that come to
life what was that like for you the
first time you watched it I mean that's
like a nerds paradise if you love
spider-man that movie is everything you
never want it to be but moreover it is
an access portal to the character no
matter who you are or what your
background is you can know nothing about
it and watch that movie and really be
caught up in wanting to wear the mask or
appreciating a world where spider-man is
that is that character like I really
loved it yeah you know you you read
Ultimates and you think all Miles
Morales is a cool character this take on
this is so great but maybe you see it in
the movie you're like wow this is I'd
watch any of these movies i watch the
spider-gwen movie I'd watch the the
penny Parker movie like yeah any of that
I can't wait to see the expansions into
it and when we spoke
Shazam had just come out we just seen
Shazam which is another like life
fulfilling movie like how is this much
heart in this character that how was
that Zachary Levi I mean yeah he is
Billy Batson a key to that yeah but also
the movies so well directed and so well
written I think such a crowd-pleaser
it's great to have that so I'm curious
with you having directed now would I
hadn't seen the movie at the time do you
watch movies differently as a director
now that you've been behind the camera a
different way um I mean I definitely
appreciate when something is technically
accomplished but I still very much enjoy
getting caught up in movies I think I'm
still a good audience
all your producers I everyone I talked
with the screening had seen it and we're
still just as they were like it was like
watching it for the first time I was
like fully leaning in that's a really
beautiful thing at a screening of all
places where like you know your your
suits so to speak or fully like there
yeah I've been in a vacuum with it I
mean I've only seen it with three
audiences at this point and they're all
somewhat predisposed to like it so I
definitely have that that well I don't
know that you ever trust compliments but
it's gaining some comfort with just
giving it to people and letting them
have their way with it good or bad I
think that's that's all I've been trying
to achieve no technical accomplishments
we can talk to endgame because that has
come out sense of seeing you and endgame
the third acts we won't spoil just in
case but the movie just escalates to a
place that I didn't think
that could be a comic on film to that
level they have a civil war and that was
the first like panel spread and this was
almost beyond comics I'm seeing an
Avengers the first time that Joss
photographed a splash page you got all
of them back to us like holy cow we are
just living in the greatest yeah I'm
Teresa watching that as a lifelong nerd
watching this change over time what has
been your perspective on the last couple
decades of all the stuff exploding and
having so many more people to talk to
you about the stuff that we always loved
well I mean I certainly appreciate that
all the things that I got my ass kicked
over loving and in grade school have now
become the most financially viable IP on
the planet that definitely is somewhat
reassuring that I spent my time in
earnest and not in vain through through
that whole thing but but all of this
evolution is just culture understanding
over a long period of time that these
characters these stories can be
represented in whatever shape or tone
serves the character or story best and
that's what I like so you know I grew up
watching reruns of the 60s Batman and
that was the best version of Batman you
were gonna get on film by the time the
Michael Keaton Batman came out you were
like oh cool Tim Burton has enough
leeway to tell a sort of dark and
artistic interpretation of this
characters and then when Nolan puts out
that Batman culture is ready to receive
something that is more dark a little
more investigative of human condition
and now we're you can even look at it
through spider-man so each of the
versions of spider-man that we've gotten
culturally has just been what the the
world is ready to absorb at the time and
so it's not that any one is much better
than the other because at the time they
were all really good like when I saw the
Sam Raimi spider-man I was like I can't
believe we're living through a time
where this is possible and now you can
go back and say okay well the best
interpretation of spider-man is as a
teenager so you get to see him as a kid
you need to see him make the mistakes
like you're you're not jumped into a
world where he's already abandoning all
of his attachments and you know refusing
to love anyone and yeah it's a it's a
great it's just a great time guys like
how happy are we oh it's perfect there's
too much content even cover and that's
that's a
went from every three years getting a
movie to once a year to now it's every
season and there's TV Hulu Netflix like
the daredevil show well and my my
familiarity my personal ability to
absorb all of that is is dwarfed by the
youth culture that has taken it as their
own and so I really love that that that
I'm able to have not just conversations
but conversations where I didn't know
what I'm talking about and we're both
talking about something that I love
deeply there's all these new iterations
of it out there what do you want to see
next
forfor this world I don't know I think
everybody that's doing it is doing
pretty good
so I'd love the same attention and focus
on quality regardless of what the title
is or what the genre is if it's if it's
done really well then it works the same
as any of the titles in any of the books
where you can just jump in and find the
character you love the most the one that
you relate to the most whether that's
iron fist or a black panther you're like
oh I see myself in this and there's and
then there's great compelling well-made
content for you it's it's like a golden
age is there any comic over the years
that you'd recommend anyone that hasn't
picked up a book if they if they found
you and we're like any comic you that's
tough man there's so many things I would
say you got to read this I always think
that Watchmen is a really good
definition of real world application to
superhero concepts but then I love the
basic wish-fulfillment stuff like
spider-man spider-man and Batman are my
favorites and so you can you can pretty
much jump in anywhere and find something
to relate to is there anything you want
to do from a filmmaking standpoint the
world of comics like weirdly when I was
watching a movie I thought a Booster
Gold like three times and I'm not sure
how that leaf happened but I was like
man I want to see a Booster Gold movie
be Jeff Jones Booster Gold yeah there's
a little blue and gold energy to your
two main characters definitely Booster
Gold flavored I was like man I'd watch
that in a second i select Booster movie
I don't know I haven't really been drawn
to it that way and I think that's the
thing you need as a director is is some
very clear vision of a particular story
you know I love I love spider-man so I I
could absent
we see myself at some point trying to
make one of those stories but the way
it's been represented on film it's
usually so innovative I'm like I never
would have thought of it I really like
it in the hands of all the people that
it's in but you of course you've had
lots of chances to kind of play with
these toys not to put too fine a point
on over over the years in animation so
it has that sort of scratch that like
you've made some of the all-time
greatest pop-culture parodies for the
record Robot Chicken is in institution
thanks I don't know I mean I've always
loved movies I've always loved acting
that's always been my priority there's
definitely been a strange I won't even
call it a detour cuz it's like a
simultaneous highway we're getting to so
deeply represent my people on film is
simultaneous with getting to play other
characters that are not considered genre
so I just I guess I just hope to be able
to keep doing that you know
well even amongst friends capturing
chemistry is so hard to do and change
land is chemistry through and through I
love this movie so very much I've can't
wait to see it again June 7th it is out
on June 7th in theaters check change
land movie.com out for a list of
theaters near you and you can get it on
itunes day and date on that day and i
cannot recommend it more I really love
this movie congratulations man thank you
thank you so much for coming to glad to
hear us my pleasure guys where did you
get this shirt this shirt Amazon
grandmas no Thanos and Amazon eyes
ghostwriter yeah thanks